bonne nouvelle pour les usagers de la
ligne u celle reliant la verrière à la
défense une reprise somme toute
partielle du trafic est prévue ce jeudi
7 mars à raison d'un train par demi
heure aux heures de pointe et un train
par heure aux heures dites creuses
à noter que la liaison sera direct entre
les gares de saint cloud et de la
défense sans desserte des gares du val
d'or de suresnes mont valérien et de
puteaux première partie de la reprise
normale du trafic le samedi 9 et le
dimanche 10 mars reprise totale du
trafic jeudi 14 mars
d'ici là et compte tenu du nombre réduit
de trains rétablie sur la ligne une
les voyageurs sont invités à continuer à
emprunter les itinéraires alternatifs
ligne c du rer ou ligne rennes jusqu'à
montparnasse pour rappel le trafic est
interrompu depuis le 24 février à la
suite d'un incendie au poste de
signalisation en gare de sèvres-ville
d'avray la destruction du poste avait
occasionné la perte des systèmes de
signalisation sur près de 3 km de voies